my thing is once I love you
like I will love you forever
and I feel like this is like for every situation
but specifically
specifically for friendships and like
platonic relationship
I just like there is a part of me that will always
care about the people that used to be friends with me
and like I don't know if it's because I have ADHD
so I like literally forget things that happen in my life
and I you know
luckily I think I'm able to remember the positive
and so what I do remember is positive um
but I do I think because of that
forget when people have done me dirty
but honestly like
I'm happy about it because I would much rather
I think move for the world with love than without
and I genuinely don't care what the situation is
like if at some point me and you are friends
even if we don't talk
even if we got into falling out
I what
I don't care if I had love for you at one point in my life and you need me or
like you need someone or like
you know something is going on and
or even if you feel like
wanna reach out and like
talk and like
talk it out and like
you know rekindle and apologize whatever
like I am always willing to hear someone out
especially if I have had love for them in the past
I just like because it
when I think back to that time period in my life when we were friends
even if we're not friends now
like I will think of you and I will think of you fond despite
you know whatever might have happened
and I think a lot of relationships that have been
in the past have run their course
you know but like
there were still always be
you know pieces of my heart with these people that were like
there for monumental like
you know milestones in my life I don't know